Congratulations on your healthy baby, right
? I
can't hear you, but I'll take you to the nursery.
me nanea
me
ana
[music]
me
good morning
[music]
ah ah ah
today's video is your brother
Okay, I'm okay..
lecithin extracted from egg
yolks is good for improving memory
.
If you were to make a clear statement about where your family is more than me, you
'd probably get drunk and rush in there
.  Your parents are also looking
forward to seeing you, so let's decide on a witcher
Eel
yes yes yes
We're just looking forward to being a real child on our own Even though I
was
born in the
wrong bed
I've decided to put in a lot of Archer's assets, such as the location or the
glamour.  Do you think your house will be accepted
? If it's
white, don't ask
anymore Ikona, I
'm going to leave early and study at the library I'll study again at a time like this To
win against my rivals It
's the usual
game No way, my brother really
was a child of a different family  No wonder I
thought it was strange.It doesn't look like any of them and I
can only study alone.
No
[music] It's a
burger.
Let
I'm not going to study [music] Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
,
oh
I tried to turn it up, but the sound got worse,
but you'll get in the way, so it'll go up in flames
.
I've seen it before whether or
not I don't care, I'm going to make a fuss at home and persuade you I don't plan on getting married I don't really know,
but
I know I can get married at 16 I
know, is
n't that right?
You're the same generation, and you're already married, and things like that are similar to mine.
I'm Erica in the rain
Orpheus Jogakuin Law Hey, battle 4 where I'm
at the
princess school Kouichi
That entry is really cute
I wonder if I'll be able to meet you if I go to my place Hasse 2 hours
Only rubbish talk
like this Cute copper seat application processing
You're a second-year high school student in the same high
school, and you're at
Megurogawa Gakuen.
You but ah ah ho ho hey, you
should be my boyfriend ah, you're a
public company,
what are you talking about?
It's no
different than marrying a man
you don't even know I don't know anything about the world of the rich
It's good to say outside the town,
look at me, use me, and try it in the summer,
how many times have you
come in, then you should have
told me sooner?
Unfortunately, reality will not end in failure
because I have no intention of cooperating with you.
"I'm going to see my parents.
"
I'm drinking, it's
slippery I can understand even in the Aspie match I
can't escape
this, it's just a matter of selling this video of the rubbing part on
the school's email form
As a result of that, my real parents also
consulted me a lot, but my 3ds
rom is not my favorite
.
What should I do to pretend to be my boyfriend
?
It's written
Show me a little bit
of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a
bit
You can use it
You're so smart, you don't need the internet
You're probably just stopping your
thoughts But that photo shows the feeling of happening, so
I'll retake it Above all, I'm not cute I'm not myself
Come over here
and au is this woman
In the first place, are you really a rich lady?
It smells
so good Please give me a video of this just for a school for blackmailers
I'm sorry, but I guess it's the feeling that
Nagi-kun set up one for this kindergarten
and took a picture together
I'm the one around that  It's because I'm a person, so it's
fine Come on,
how do you choose
this outfit?
My friend who remembers that I was wearing a link coordination with my boyfriend I
don't feel like we
're really close.
It costs 495,000 yen in a bar style.
I bought it as a supply item for the ministry,
Osho-sama, what kind of family line
do you have?
Then you have to make it look stronger
Next prediction
[Music]
It's more than before I can't say anything more Do
you need to look strong to show your parents who are borrowing a little bit of
money?
Orphan,
Hojo power contract, educated black
man, Asaka this guy, maybe Mr. Amano said that
he's a
low-key guy, so why are you
filming like
that?  It's no good, it's all about Setsu-san, haha ​​My
little sister's solo
photos, I think it's a good photo that conveys the feeling of the atmosphere at that time.
That's why I try not to edit photos too much
.
I thought he was in a world far removed from me,
but he might be unexpectedly normal
.
I didn't have a collar-shaped boyfriend, so
these guys returned
Koasaka.  Stop being a famous teacher I'm going to go to the
pure girls' sky o You're a young lady, that's
why we're following you Don't
worry, this guy is innocent, so stop How to say it
Contract boyfriend car
[music]
I'm happy I'm
off or I'll answer honestly What
should I do?
Imamura, who is being
harassed, get away from the way you say
it
.  Don't go near
ni ah ah ah ni ah ah ah
you won't know unless you meet a good face
That's the end
Umi no Ie
All the flowers that have been taught are
family and
parents
It's okay,
eh, it's
cute Don't
mess up the place
If you make a dark mortgage, it's ok,
but it's not the best, but hey, it
's from the flaming video
I saw it, I
promise
I'll go with guts like Nagi-kun
Ah~
If you're going to do it anyway, do it as hard as you can
[Music] It
's time for the young lady to go home, isn't
it?
I'll set up a video for you, please do so Um,
I'll never see you again
[Music]
I'm sorry for that.
I was worried I was
worried they wouldn't come because it's late I
'm glad
these people are my real Otani
It's something we've discussed and decided,
but after
all, both our children and our foster children are
important, because it's been 16 years, isn't it?
No, what
are you talking about? I was surprised when I saw the picture my daughter sent
me.
I'll introduce you to my
daughter Erika, who was
mistaken for you
.
On this day, I got a
fiancée.
Well then,
up until now, I
would have just let it go, but now that I'm
fiancéed, I
can't take it easy.
[Music]
I wonder if she's smarter than me
If I win 1st place, I'll confess to this woman
[Music]
Nogi-kun is a good name
Voice is a fierce
story
of love
]
i want to see ni
[music]